hi everyone i'm very happy to be at itcs
2022
to talk about my recent work
more dominantly choose for multi-task
peer prediction with a finite number of
tasks
so let's start
um so i'm considering
we have two um people here and they are
us to read several restaurants
and um we want them to provide their
honest high quality reviews
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
take
their feedbacks whether they uh like it
or dislike it as our inputs and then
we're gonna use a reward system to
calculate their reward
and to return the reward to
two agents here
okay so uh for this reward systems like
uh one way we can like one traditional
way to design it is like we just use
flat payments
but the problem is that that actually
gives the two agents no incentive
to read like these restaurants and
another thing we can do is we can do
this bar check like randomly pick
a question a rating task and to check
whether they tell the truth or not
but it is impossible because they are
actually
providing their subjective opinions and
there is no way to check it
and the third thing is
okay
maybe we just pay this to agents based
on the number of agreements they have
like for example if there are like five
uh restaurants they have they have like
uh the same opinions we're gonna pay
them like point five dollars something
like that
but the problem is first
it's possible that alice and bob they
have very different tastes
and in such case
even if they tell the truth
um they may have like very little
agreements
and and in such case like
they will not be incentivized to to tell
the truth
and another is like if we tell them
we're gonna pay you according to the
number of agreements what they can do is
they can just ignore
the uh the identity of the restaurant
and they just like see they like the
restaurant all the time
in such case they don't need to pay any
attention they don't need any effort but
they can get the highest amount of
payments
so that we already start their incentive
so then it actually comes to the
question here is like we want them to we
want to design proper reverse system
that can avoid these issues can
incentivize
them to provide informative reviews and
this question
is called multitask peer prediction and
it is first proposed by descripton
gauche in 2013
okay
so uh to address this question
uh
there are other words but today i'm
going to introduce a kind of framework
uh one framework is called the mutual
information paradigm
and
in this framework so the the trick here
is that first we're gonna see
like for example we have like infinite
so
oh sorry
so uh let's just see like we have like
infinite number of restaurants or rating
tasks
and we can see alice and bob their
feedback as id samples
and of some like maybe random variable
x and y
and then because we have infinite number
of these id samples
so we can estimate
the joint distribution
x and y
and then
we will use the this definition is
mutual information
uh defined by shannon and the mutual
information actually calculates the
correlation between x and y
and it takes the joint distribution of x
and y as input and outputs
a non-negative value so like
let me explain what is joint
distribution here so let's see
if they like it we say yes
if they don't like it we say no
and this is the
journal distribution here is the two
byte we can also think it as two by two
matrix
um so this is actually
the probability that for a random
restaurant both alice and bob like it
and this is probability for a random
restaurant alice like it likes it but
bob doesn't like
like it so this is this joint
distribution
like joint distribution matrix
okay
so
the point is that the mutual information
actually measures the correlation
the correlation between
x and y so in such case
if alice and bob z have very similar
tastes they're going to have very high
correlation but even though they have
very different tastes they can still
have very high correlations like maybe
it's negative correlated but doesn't
matter mutual information is non-active
so this kind of way to
kind of like pay them the creation to
incentivize them to provide informative
and the behind the mathematical reason
is here so let's first see this running
example here
so
the point is that
um
for example this point four point one
point two point three thing
is the original joint distribution
between
alex and bob's reports
and
maybe as she can actually perform a
strategy
and the strategy
we can just see this strategy just means
that
if alice likes a restaurant she gonna
say she likes her she's gonna tell the
truth
and this color means here
if she doesn't like the restaurant with
with point five her beauty she gonna say
she still like the restaurant so
this strategy actually is like less
informative strategy
and the point is that
um if we use mutual information
as long as perform a strategy
the mutual information can be smaller
and
this is a mathematical form is that
previously the joint distribution is you
and as long as alex performs strategy
is equivalent is equivalent to as we're
multiplying a transition matrix and here
this transition matrix is like
every column sums to one and they are
like elements are non-negative
and it is same as we multiply a
transition matrix on the left
and
this is called the data processing
inequality of mutual information it
guarantees that
this will decrease mutual information so
okay so the point is that because mutual
information
satisfies data processing inequality
thus if we pay them according to this
their strategy
will decrease their strategy is also a
data process method and their strategy
will decrease their payments
so that is why
i mean in this paper we just call it
dominantly
um truthful
and
um
it's just like the strategy decreases
their payment so
like for alice regardless bob gonna see
she shouldn't perform any strategy here
and it's same for bob so that is why if
we use this neutral information paradigm
we can naturally have this
good incentive property
okay
but the problem is like one thing i
kind of mentioned before
it actually needs infinite number of
tasks like the restaurants they need to
read
infinite number of restaurants to
estimate to perfectly estimate the drone
distribution
and
what if we have
only 10 tasks like 10 restaurants
in such case we can only get a frequency
matrix it's like we just get empirical
frequency
and if there is only 10 it's not even a
good estimation
and one solution is like we can usually
assume that
somebody only care about their expected
payments
and in such cases unbiased as matter
of mutual information is
sufficient but however
the channel neutral information doesn't
have unbiased estimator it's because
i'm not sure whether you uh
remember not
so in the
definition of the channel mutual
information which i won't
uh
write in detail here but it has a log
function there
and this log function is this you just
cannot
estimate it always finite unbiased
estimated with finite number of tasks
so in such case we need a new definition
of mutual information
but still we want to satisfy data
processing inequality
and also
the most important thing is we won't we
can unbiased
estimated with finite number tasks
and that is this work
proposed the determinant-based mutual
information
so it's actually very natural definition
so remember the joint distribution
matrix we mentioned before the reason i
write it in a formatted matrix just
because of this
we can naturally define
the mutual information between two
random variables
as the determinant of their joint
distribution matrix
and we just take the absolute value to
guarantee it's non-negative
okay so this is the
running example here
okay
so the determining based neutral
information naturally satisfies
sorry this should be capital u here
naturally satisfy the data process
inequality
because the determinant actually
satisfies the multiplicative property
and the determinant of the transition
matrix is always less than one
and also
the important things here is remember
that women only get empirical frequency
matrix it's like they read 10 restaurant
and three of them they both like it two
of them one like when one dislike and
one of them they both they just don't
like it
we get this empirical frequency and by
some
uh
like a transformations we can
actually prove that expectation the
determinant of this frequency matrix
it's actually proportional to the
determinant of the joint distribution
and you may ask
like
then
like this absolute value how can we deal
with that
and
the the trick is
we just like use the square
and if we use a square
we can actually
um
divide the tasks into two parts using
one part to estimate
uh something and use another part and
then multiply them together
you can refer your refer to the paper
for more details but the point is
the thing i just want you to know here
in today's talk is that the reason this
thing is true
it's just because the determinant is
actually has a polynomial format if you
remember the formula of determinant
and it's also like if we square it it's
still polynomial and this is a
fundamental reason it can be unbiasedly
estimated by finite number of tasks like
for example
um
if we like
talk about this binary crease and this
is the both like it this is the joint
distribution matrix
and this is like um
maybe deposit
okay like for example if we want to
unbindlessly estimate this this very
simple we just need one task right we
just need one task
and we set up our indicator random
variable whether they both like it if
they both like it it's one if they
otherwise it's zero in such case
expectation is this thing we want to
and
if we want to
estimate unmind city estimate the
product of these two
values
together
we just need two tasks
and
there
actually remember we assume the id every
time there is independent id assumption
there and
we can just set up like two indicator
variable this is for the first task and
we multiply the second task
and
the point is that in such case because
the tasks are independent
so
expectation
it equals the
expected this is for the first task
this is for the second
and in expectation we can just like
decompose it
and the expectation of this is this and
the expectation of that is this
so that is why so
the point is that as long as we just
want to estimate the polynomial format
of the the elements in the joint
distribution
we just need a finite number of tests
and in fact
it depends on the degree of the
polynomial if the phenomenon's degrees d
we just need d
tasks to unbiasedly estimate it just use
this
okay so that is a fundamental
thing here
and remember
in today's work we will talk about more
dominantly truthful
mechanism and the previous process
actually reduced this mechanism design
question
to information measure design and
remember
as long as my information manager
satisfies two property
then we are done the first property is
data processing equality this one
and
this one guarantees that dominance
issues strategy decreases payments
and the second property is very
important is it should like the
determinant-based mutual information it
should have a polynomial format
like remember the previous process i i
performed in the previous slide as long
as it has a polynomial format it can be
unbiased may estimate with a finite
number of tasks and the number of tags
we need is a degree of polynomial so
okay so to to address this question we
are essentially trying to find the
information manager satisfies these two
properties simultaneously
that's the key
and
here comes to the most important slide
in this talk and if you understand this
slide is like just i think this is all
you need to know for this work
is this new definition of mutual
information
called volume mutual information
okay so
um
the volume mutual information so
first we see here
so the data processing equality there is
like remember
we want to
um
find mutual information for all
transition matrix for our joint
distribution we want to have this
inequality here
and this transition matrix multiplied on
the left actually defines a partial
order
so the reason why this is partial order
because if you
multiply some transition matrix on the
left and you multiply it again
the product of the true transition
measure is still transition matrix so
that naturally defines the partial order
this way a distribution is less than
another transfusion as long as we can
find a transition matrix such that u
prime equals
t
multiplies u
and this is the partial order
and the data processing inequality
essentially means that we want to design
a mountain function
a monotone function
on this partial order so one way to
define a mountain function on partial
order the very natural idea to define
mountain function partial order is that
maybe we just try to count how many for
random distribution we just try to count
how many john distribution are less than
it
and
maybe this is in property it but
i don't know whether it helps you to
understand it but if like if like clever
is something satisfied partial order
and if you want to know how clever you
are
you can actually count the number of
people that are less clever than you
and the point is if it's satisfied
partial order then someone is less
clever than you
um
like the people are less clever
if someone is less clever than you and
then people less claustral than him or
her is also less than clever than you so
this is maybe inappropriate so the point
is that is this partial order thing it's
like it's natural it's we can just
define
uh how
informative a job distribution is by the
number of transitions are less
informative
than it and we use this as a definition
as less informative
and we actually
call
this the lower set
for every contribution we call
the
contribution we call the set of order
attributions
less than it as is lower sets
and the volume mutual information is
defined it's actually a continuous that
is not discrete
so we define it as the volume
of the lower set
and still i want to see that the reason
the fundamental reason is that because
it satisfied partial order so if
your prime is less than u
then we have this step theory thing is
like the
lower set of this u prime is gonna be
a subset
of the lower set of u
because it is a partial order
and in such case
the volume
gonna be
smaller than
the volume u and
then
this actually naturally defines
a mountain function
on
this partial order so this is the idea
behind the wall of mutual information
okay and this is why
this is why it naturally satisfies data
processing inequality
okay
so
um so that's how we define the volume
neutral information we get the joint
distribution matrix and we calculate the
volume of its lower set defined on this
partial order
and remember that we can actually use
when we calculate like this is like
something
in this space
and this may be u
and this may be
u prime
and in this whole space we if we
calculate the volume we can actually use
any density function we want as long as
this density function is not negative
and
so forget about this this is not
important this is not important
and
the point is that we can tune the
density function
but still satisfy this
monotonicity
which is another term for data
processing equality
and if we use uniform density uniform
density means like the density is equals
equals to one everywhere in such case
interestingly we can prove that this
volume measured information is actually
the determinant-based mutual information
and another very
interesting
property is here
if we use polynomial density
like the density the density is the
non-negative function on the space of
the joint distribution if we use
polynomial density
we will get polynomial it's not directly
you still need to multiply something but
the point is we can get polynomial
volume mutual information so actually
that solves our question right because
the definition of small volume mutual
information
naturally satisfy data processing
inequality and also we can prove that
if we
we can set our density function as any
polynomial as any non-negative
polynomial as we
we like and we can get a family of
polynomial volume mutual information and
that gives us a family of new dominantly
truthful
mechanism and we only need a finite
number of tasks so that actually solves
the question
okay
and actually to want to give more
intuition here
so let's consider the binary case so
everything we talked about before
although previously i used binary case
that running example but everything i
talked before actually applies to the
manual case
okay so this binary case
um considering we
have this two by two joint
distribution matrix
and
they should sum to one and every one is
non-active
and
we can use xyz
because w has no freedom here we can use
xyz as the space but
to have a better visualization
i actually
use stp here and we can prove that all
possible stp
equals or possible this
um
john distribution matrix
and
so the reason i use stp here because
both s t and p there belongs to zero
zero to one
and if we use x y and z and they have
some constraints there
um so i use stp here and
and then the the the distribution all
possible transition can be seen as a
cube
and then
we just pick so this is because i want
to christmas here so then we pick a
slice of this cube and it's just we fix
p we fix p
and in such case we only have s and t as
our
variables
and in such case we can actually
draw
so if u is the contribution
and we want to draw the lower set
remember the lower set is all possible t
u
and t is a possible transition matrix
and this is the
lower set of u
and in such case this is a convex set
and we just like draw the
uh
the corner here which corresponds to
a transition matrix identity transition
matrix
permutation transition matrix all one or
zero something like that
and in such case this is a convex set
this this convex set is actually this
blue
uh sorry it's not blue it's it's green
area
and we can see that if we draw some
for example if we draw some u prime less
than u and within this and we can see
that the
lower set of u prime is going to be
something like this
and it is belongs to the lower set of
you
okay so that hope this can give you some
intuition some of which like uh position
in your mind
for this lower set distribution spacing
and
the thing is that we can tune the
density and get very different volume
mutual information
so here i just show everything in one
slice because it's easy for us to
visualize it and
um so this volumetric information here i
just this is a controller
this is a contours here okay
so remember that
um
we're gonna
use this uh we can change every density
we like and i'm gonna show you three
different density functions and this is
the plan one is the uniform density and
in such case so this is actually the
um
volume corresponded is actually the
determinant-based mutual information
because i said before the union uniform
density leads to determinant-based
mutual information and this is the
contour
and
if we we can also use this mountain
or basin shape and it gives you very
different contour shape and the point of
this figure is just shows yet that
it's possible that we can just like tune
the shape of the density function to
tune the volume information and if in
some scenarios you figure out you want
the controls to be like this then you
can use this density even other
scenarios you want the controls like
this you can use that
density it's very flexible
okay
and another
thing i want to
mention here is like one
music information a very
artificial mutual information is this so
we just like define this uh
set of thresholds
and
for the
joint distribution that is more
informative than these thresholds we
give them one
otherwise it's zero so because this like
stress holds mutual information and it's
actually corresponds to a stress whole
payment scheme
but the part the i mean
the same thing
we just need infinite number of samples
rating tasks to estimate the joint
distribution
and
so if we want only one finite number of
tasks we just want very natural idea we
just want some polynomial
to approximate it and we cannot directly
use polynomial to
to approximate because it may violate
the monotonicity and also violates the
dominantly chosenness
so
the thing we can do here
is so this indeed this threshold mutual
information
actually corresponds to we the volume
neutral information
why we
actually set this threshold with
infinite number of density
and zero outerwear
um is direct delta function
and
in that case remember this uh volume
mutual information
so
if we use this density the direct delta
density we can get this threshold mutual
information
and in such case what we can do is we
can use polynomials to approximate the
direct delta density
and then is correspond to a wall of
mutual information which is
it's polynomial
it's also polynomial and it's
um
it satisfy data processing inequality
and
and and more importantly it actually
approximates so we can see like
from this we we get like better and
better polynomial approximation for this
direct delta density
and we're gonna get better
volume mutual information
to approximate it
okay
and the reason i mentioned the stress
hosting
because in the paper i didn't cover in
this talk is that
this paper actually provides a tractable
effort incentive optimization goal
but it has some like model constraint
that is discussed in the paper and but
the point is that with this
effort incentive like in some situation
we can prove that the stress holds
mutual information corresponds to the
threshold payment scheme actually
can
actually can incentivize
the effort the best
and in such case if we want to
use that mechanism but still we find a
number of tasks we can just use the
trick i mentioned before use the
sequence of volume transformation
approximately that can
actually approximate the stress hold
payment scheme
and also it is i mentioned before um
polynomial satisfied data processing
equality so everything's fine there
okay so this actually concludes this
talk
um this this work actually provides a
family reward system
and the volume mutual information
mechanism
and it's like we first get the volume
mutual information
and then we just use
a finite number of
finite samples
to estimate it
and then
we can use this estimation of our
payment and that is the definition for
the volume neutral information mechanism
and because the volume mutual
information satisfies data processing
equality we can prove that it is it has
strict its strict dominant strategy to
stallion equivalent informative strategy
and also it doesn't need any prior
knowledge and only requires finite
number of tasks
and i think
for the future work in addition um
in addition to empirical validation of
this mechanism
um one thing i think can be um
interesting is to apply this volume
military information
in other areas like the design the loss
function
in the learning
scenario so one constraint i want to
talk about here is like
although this following mutual
information
actually
satisfies property determinant-based
mutual information also satisfied
but it can have very complicated formula
and
maybe the agents
the human agents they're gonna it's it's
not easy for them to understand the
reward system if they want to understand
it
but if we can apply it in the learning
scenario to incentivize
uh to design loss functions we do not
need have that issue issue and also we
can it's very flexible it's like we can
just like tune the density
and
and to get any
shape counters we like
and that may have like
um that can be nice in some scenarios i
hope so this is one future direction i
think maybe interesting to explore
and
[Music]
thanks